[Music]
on this saturday night the new coveted
19 variant lands in canada
ontario confirms two cases of the more
contagious
uk strain as millions in england face
even
tougher restrictions a boxing day like
no
other non-essential shops close and
restaurants are take out only as
all of ontario locks down it's like
putting people in jail without them
actually committing the crime
why some businesses say the new measures
are unfair
plus combing for clues in nashville we
have over 500 investigative leads and
we're following up on every one of those
investigators scour the scene after a
mysterious christmas day blast
global national with robin gill
reporting tonight
colleen christie good evening thanks for
joining us we begin with breaking news
on the spread of covet 19 in canada
in ontario two people have tested
positive for that new more contagious
strain of the virus
which was first detected in the uk and
officials don't know how they got it
it's a rattling development for the
province which just today entered a
sweeping lockdown to try to get its
surging case numbers under control
for the last 12 days ontario has
recorded more than 2
000 new cases a day between yesterday
and today
more than 4 300 new cases were confirmed
and 81 more deaths reported
for more on what we know about this new
strain in ontario let's bring in
global's abigail beeman
abigail what can you tell us about it
colleen ontario officials say the couple
from durham region are now
self-isolating and notably they had no
known travel history nor exposure while
health canada says it's monitoring
closely
but also points out there is no evidence
yet whether the new strains cause people
to get more sick
or have an impact on vaccine
effectiveness while the scientific head
of ontario's covet 19 advisory group
tells global news the fact this is
community transmission
suggests there's a high probability
there are more cases out there
and he says it's more important than
ever people follow the new
lockdown rules from
stampeding shoppers my first time to
order online
to curbside pickup like everything else
in covet 19 riddle 2020
boxing day is different we're offering
different ways to shop online
whether it's through curbside pickups
ordering directly to your home
so far as you can see our parking lot
has been steady new restrictions are now
in place across ontario for 28 days in
the south and 14 days in the north
non-essential stores closed limited
capacity at the rest
and students will learn virtually when
the break is over
there's pushback at the ford
government's decision to let some big
box store stay open
they should just for groceries only
just for the stuff that you really need
in ontario and quebec are the big parts
of the canadian economy right so when
you're locking them down 14 to 28 days
and restricting them to curbside
delivery as the extent of their
retail experience it's going to have an
impact right not surprisingly retail is
a big part of
the canadian economy the owner of ebb
and flow knows that
sherry wallace made no money in 2020.
it's like putting people in jail without
them actually committing the crime
like many others including ottawa's
mayor and top doctor she's pushing back
against the sweeping lockdown
with ottawa's case numbers relatively
low there's currently
one patient in the icu wallace's
customers can shop online but she isn't
expecting similar sales
regardless of what was reported in the
financial post by a man
women like to see it touch it try it on
feel it
we do not like to return it to the post
office
while many health care workers are on
the front lines this day holiday or not
this emergency room physician says
morale among her colleagues is low
we don't have to have applause and you
don't have to give us free food but
you know we do ask please wear a mask
and stay home
she knows the lockdown can be
frustrating and says health care workers
appreciate the sacrifices people make
when they follow the rules
in an effort to lower case numbers
abigail bieben global news
ottawa millions of people in the uk
are now living under tough new
restrictions as officials scramble to
contain that more contagious variant of
cobit 19.
in total more than 40 percent of all
people in england are now under
tier 4 restrictions that means
non-essential businesses are closed and
people are being warned
to stay home the uk's new variant has
now been detected in sweden health
authorities there say a traveler from
the uk
became ill and tested positive
switzerland
france and spain have also confirmed
their first cases of the new strain
all with links to the uk japan
is tightening its borders after
detecting several cases of the new
strain
according to public broadcaster nhk
starting monday
non-resident foreigners will be barred
from entering the country
the ban will last until the end of
january
the u.s now has nearly 19 million
coveted cases and today unemployment
benefits may run out
it'll leave about 14 million americans
with no money coming in
president donald trump who's at his
florida resort tweeting more baseless
claims about election fraud
has refused to sign a government
spending bill and covet 19 relief
package
if it doesn't go through a partial
government shutdown could begin tuesday
leaving millions of federal workers
without a paycheck jennifer johnson has
more
as u.s president donald trump spends his
holiday in florida
an unwelcome present has arrived for
millions of out-of-work americans
their unemployment benefits have
officially run out after the president
refused to sign congresses
900 billion dollar coronavirus aid bill
i try not try not to dwell on the what
if
what will i do next because to be honest
i run out of what i'm going to do now
millions of people have gone without
real paychecks for several months
after the pandemic shut down businesses
across the country
i can't provide for my kids like i
normally would
the president has so far refused to sign
the 2.3 trillion dollar spending package
which included the pandemic aid because
it gave just 600 dollars to most
americans
nor has he vetoed it which congress
could override democrats want to
increase the eight amount to two
thousand dollars but republicans say
they won't agree to that
they can't think of a worse way to greet
christmas
than to fail to sign the bill the bill
also included 8 billion dollars for
covid19 vaccine distribution
as numbers of new cases and deaths
continue to surge
over 118 thousand people are
hospitalized
battling this often deadly virus in
isolation it is scary
because you just don't know what you're
going to
expect you never know how many hands
you're going to have to hold
whenever there's no families that are
able to be there medical experts fear
the worse is yet to come
with 8 million people a day traveling
through airports another surge of the
virus is expected
doctors are frustrated so many people
believe it's safe to fly
this concept of safe travel it just
doesn't exist
you can't glove sanitize and try to test
your way out of that risk it's virtually
impossible
while hospitals await a post-holiday
rush those who have now lost their
jobless benefits wait for help
the democratic control house plans to
meet monday but the problem can't be
solved
until the republican-controlled senate
goes back to work too
jennifer johnson global news washington
in nashville tennessee authorities are
still trying to piece together details
about a christmas day blast which they
say was an intentional act
according to the associated press
investigators have identified a possible
person of interest in connection
with the detonation of a camper van in
the city's downtown early yesterday
multiple police agencies including the
fbi are searching a property in a
nashville suburb
the fbi says it's following up on more
than 500 tips from the public
i am fairly confident we'll be able to
identify an individual or ascertain what
has occurred we just can take us some
time
police were called to the scene at
around six o'clock christmas morning for
reports of gunfire
when they arrived a warning was
broadcast from the vehicle saying it
would blow up the explosion badly
damaged dozens of buildings at least
three people were hurt all recovering in
hospital with non-life-threatening
injuries
coming up cancer game changer how a bc
lab is now making the rarest drug in the
world
researchers are looking for the magic
bullet that will eradicate cancer and
they may be
one step closer a lab in bc has found a
way to produce an extremely rare cancer
drug one that
previously relied on limited supplies of
radioactive waste
jordan armstrong explains how this major
breakthrough
could make a major difference let's
start with an explanation of the drug
researchers are so excited about five
years ago a german man riddled with
cancerous tumors and weeks away from
death was given an untested drug
which contained a radioactive isotope
called
actinium-225 eight months later the
tumors
had disappeared we're seeing cancer
basically be
eliminated in some cases and so those
are very early results but very exciting
ones
problem is actinium-225 is incredibly
rare
today most of the global supply comes
from american radioactive waste but
it's barely enough to treat a handful of
patients a year
this is where triumph comes in
researchers at the ubc facility have
found a way to make it
in the lab using this triumph's
high energy cyclotron here's how it
works
the cyclotron speeds up
protons at to three quarters of the
speed of light
using electromagnets and so it basically
shoots it down a beam line it basically
blasts it apart and creates
hundreds and hundreds of different
isotopes and one of them is actinium-225
which is nicknamed the rarest drug on
earth but triumph's ceo
hopes to change that because we have
this incredible cyclotron
at triumph we have the capability so the
theoretical capability that we can scale
up to produce
many many thousands of doses obesity
cancer researchers says this could open
the door to a whole new line of
treatment
it's very hard to develop resistance
with actinium
so we anticipate that this will be an
effective third fourth line of treatment
in addition to the other treatments that
are available so what's next
step one establish a supply chain step
two bc
clinical trials hopefully in the next 18
months cancer research
we're seeing a lot of progress uh it's
like you know wanting to send a man to
the moon you know
how or women to the moon you know how to
get there
you just need sufficient resources to
develop the infrastructure
a 2020 homegrown triumph
for nuclear medicine jordan armstrong
global news vancouver
up next canadian politicians come
together
it's been an interesting year in
canadian politics marked by pandemic
cooperation and conflict but the
holidays can work magic on even the
toughest in ottawa
and what better way to put politics
aside than with story time
and santa claus
[Music]
well boom sana have all the children
from ottawa been good this year
well mostly answered the little old elf
as he bustled across the busy workshop
to santa's desk
santa peered down at the elf from behind
the tall teetering piles of letters
that the children of ottawa had sent him
mostly
as santa looking over the top of his
glasses
yes they've all been especially good in
the last few days
said the elf jolly good chuckled santa
then we better get their presents loaded
up even though the sack of presents
was really really big and the elves were
really really small
they seemed to have no trouble loading
it into santa's sleigh
though how they managed to fit such a
big sack
into one little sleigh even they didn't
know but somehow
they did blended
boom santa we're ready to go they're
not quite santa said one little old elf
one of our reindeer is missing missing
which reindeer is missing
ask santa the youngest one santa said
the elf
it's his first flight tonight i've
called him and called him but
just then a young reindeer strolled up
munching on a large carrot
where have you been asked santa but the
youngest reindeer was crunching so
loudly that it was no wonder he hadn't
heard the little old elf calling
oh well never mind said santa giving the
reindeer a little wink
he took out his santa nav and tapped in
the coordinates for ottawa
this will guide us to ottawa in no time
with a flick of the reins
and a jerk of the harness off they went
racing through the sky ho ho ho
laugh santa we'll soon have these
presents
delivered to by town santa's slave flew
through the starry night
heading south across the arctic ocean on
they flew in the wintery air
crossing over nunavut in the wink of an
eye the slayer was flying over hudson
bay and on towards ontario
the youngest reindeer was very excited
he had never been away from the north
pole before
they were just nearing gatineau park
when suddenly
they ran into a blizzard snowflakes
whirled around the sleigh
they couldn't see a thing the youngest
reindeer was getting a bit worried
but santa didn't seem concerned in two
miles said the santa nav in a bossy
ladies voice
keep left at the next star but ma'am
santa bluster
i can't see any stars in all this snow
and soon
they were hopelessly lost then
through the blizzard the youngest
reindeer heard a faint ringing sound
ding dong
he looked over at the old reindeer with
the red nose but he had his head down
red nose i wonder who that could be ding
dong
ding dong ding dong ding dong
there was that sound again like church
bells ringing
the youngest reindeer turned around to
look at santa but santa wasn't listening
he seemed to be arguing with a little
box with buttons on it
with a flick of the harness and a jerk
of the reins the youngest reindeer gave
a sharp tug
and headed off toward the sound of the
belts pulling santa and his sleigh
behind him
whoa cried santa as he pulled his hat
straight
what's going on then to his surprise he
heard a ringing sound
well done young reindeer he shouted
cheerfully
it must be the bells of notre dame
cathedral basilica
don't worry children santa is coming oh
crunch then he heard something as it
plummeted through the snow clouds
you have arrived said the santa nav
unhelpfully finally when the snow had
died down
and the clouds parted santa discovered
exactly where they were
stuck right at the very top of the peace
tower on parliament
hill everybody paul
the reindeer pulled with all their might
until
at last with a screeching noise the
sleigh
scraped clear of the tower and santa
steered them
safely past the golden triangle along
rideau canal
and down into commissioner's park
luckily there was no real damage done
but the packages had all been
jumbled up santa quickly sorted out the
presents into order again
all right said santa thanks to this
young reindeer
i know where we are now don't worry
children
santa is coming in house after house
santa delved inside his sack for
packages of every shape and size
he piled them under the christmas trees
and carefully filled up the stockings
with surprises
in house after house the good children
of ottawa had left out a large plate of
cookies
a small glass of milk and a big crunchy
carrot
santa took a little bite out of each
cookie a tiny sip of milk
wiped his beard and popped the carrots
into a sack
finally santa had delivered the last
present on his long canada list
great moons and stars sighed santa it's
past midnight and my sack seems as heavy
as ever
i hope i haven't forgotten anyone santa
opened his sack to check but it was full
of
juicy crunchy carrots santa divided the
carrots among
all the reindeer well done he said
patting the youngest reindeer gently on
the nose
but the youngest reindeer didn't hear
him he was too busy munching
then it was time to set off for home
santa reset his
santa nav once more to the north pole
and soon
they were speeding over nathan phillips
square across the great lakes
past olympic park and above mount logan
through the crisp
starry night ho ho ho laugh santa
merry christmas canada happy holidays
merry christmas
and mostly happy new year i know it's
going to be a better one
that's global national for this saturday
night i'm colleen christie
tonight's your canada is regina beach
saskatchewan we love to see your part of
this beautiful country
email your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching i'll see you back
here tomorrow have a great night
[Music]